el ciclo celular no es de la clase de
cosas que ocurre sin control en realidad
hay un montón de regulaciones en juego
de hecho hay dos momentos clave donde
tenemos una amplia regulación del ciclo
celular el primer punto de control es
justo aquí entre las fases que 1 y s
regulamos antes de llegar al punto de la
replicación del adn el otro punto de
control importante es justo aquí entre
la fase 2 y el paso donde brincamos
hacia la mitosis ahora hay ciertas
proteínas que regulan este proceso las
dos principales se llaman sin masas
dependientes de ciclina sse como
recordarán si nasa es algo que agrega un
grupo fosfato así que escribiremos entre
paréntesis más
agrega un grupo fosfato y este agrega un
grupo fosfato a otras enzimas o
proteínas ya sea para activarlas o
inactivar las y éstas y nasas
dependientes de ciclina se trabajan en
conjunto con una proteína de la que
puedas adivinar su nombre inclinas ya
que está sin asas dependen de ellas no
es así
así que una cosa que es importante notar
es que está sin asas dependientes de
cycling as o sed de casa están siempre
presentes todos los diferentes tipos
están siempre presentes en la célula
pero su forma y función predeterminada
es estar inactivas necesitarán ser
activadas por estas proteínas cycling as
el punto de regulación aquí es que las
cíclicas específicas se crean en tiempos
específicos
la razón del por qué ambas son tan
importantes es que cuando tienes una
asignación de pendientes de ciclina c de
camps ésta sólo se activa cuando se une
con una ciclina específica sólo hasta
ese momento se activarán y la sedecap es
la parte esencial de este complejo es
por ello que en que uno vemos la
producción de las cíclicas de ie
después veremos una sed de k-2 unida a
una ciclina e y al mismo tiempo
tendremos de k4 unida a la ciclina de
entonces está sin asas activadas
específicamente el complejo cdk4 ciclina
de fosforila harán una proteína llamada
rv así que dibujaremos una pequeña
reacción por aquí donde sumaremos un
grupo fosfato a la proteína rv entonces
cuando se fosforila la erp no puede
inhibir la replicación del adn como se
supone que suele hacer el grupo fosfato
lo inactiva y esto es lo que va
sucediendo a medida que avanzamos en
nuestro ciclo celular en la fase s se
produce ciclina am de nuevo la ciclina
formará un complejo con la sed de cada
dos
activar la replicación del adn y de la
misma forma se produce ciclina ve sólo
en la fase 2 ya que el complejo cdk1
ciclina ve es capaz de activar cuál es
el paso que piensas que activará bien la
mitosis o la división celular entonces
es importante reconocer que para pasar
estos puntos de control deben de estar
presentes estas proteínas cíclicas para
que puedan inhibir las proteínas que
impiden la síntesis del adn o su
replicación o promover la producción de
proteínas que son necesarias en la
mitosis